merci
merci merci beaucoup merci beaucoup mesdames et
messieurs
bien je veux dire c'est vraiment euh fantastique
de vous voir si nombreux ce soir et j'espère
que vous appréciez le spectacle
salut tout le monde j'ai dit le plus en suivant
minam avec vous dans
les rues  comme votre dévotion votre voix
aussi bien mesdames à Santa Mon ce soir
euh eh bien ouais je leur ai fait quelques problèmes
aussi moi eh bien quelque chose de très important
à vous dire
noix de cajou mm Papa boisé ouais oui le
tonneau de film était un très lundi interpréter les railleries
et D bien  ok ouais ce soir semaines aussi
gringo Shilla et Sasha tous ensemble sont
ici Radha allez